It's rehearsal night for Abbey Road.
A Beatles tribute band in Charlottesville, Virginia.
Lifelong Beatles fans, they're looking forward to their next gig.
They'll perform at a local record store in honor of the release...
...of the new digitally remastered Beatles catalog,...
...the complete Beatles collection.
Tribute band founding member Paul Olko...
...says anticipating the release brings back childhood memories.
I remember them coming, of course, to the Ed Sullivan show.
I remember the endless girls screaming.
I remember their unusual personalities in their relaxed way of handling the media...
...and their constant humor that they were bringing in to the fun of their interviews.
Four years ago, after legal papers were signed by the catalog's owners,...
...engineers started cleaning up all 12 albums using state-of-the-art equipment.
The remastered CDs will give listeners the choice of mono and stereo,...
...and will also contain original art work...
...and many documentaries about how each album was made.